[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pascal alesi alors comme sodebo big boy
y allant d'un personnel je veux dire ce
qui va se passer là ça reste entre nous
un bijou pas mal cette partie c'était la
balle on y va on y va on arrive à point
en trois points gagne on attend le
perdant doit enlever le reste le reste
du peu que j'ai déjà oui oui ah ben je
mets tout nu à la ba oui si je perds
voisine attention c'est parti à trois
points jean l'est parce que et ça ils
n'ont pas voulu qu'on voit la marque y
croit vraiment qu'il ya des mecs qui
vont regarder la marque de la balle de
ping pong où qu'ils aillent mis du
scotch dessus son magnifique quand même
dans le dos l'équipe attention aux trois
points c'est parti sebbar des aléas les
pascal
[Applaudissements]
attenti revient voilà j'aime bien j'aime
bien c'est bien coupé leurs menus soient
là bas c'est le jeu est bien sûr de toi
tu es surtout n'y étaient pas prêtées
pas prêt et n'était pas ça n'a pas
d'importance allons-y oh lalala lalala
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
d'abord tu commences à avoir froid
j'aime
présomptueux c'est la toge et celles aux
attentes a gagné 3-2 non redonne robin
du nord et sud après c'est sûr il ya dix
ans je suis allé au bout
[Applaudissements]
dieu
elle ne sera pas la natation du hockey
de partout
[Applaudissements]
non ça c'est celle là ça suffit
parce qu il ya d autres s'y ajouter des
chaudières mais la pelote à 21h quand
même à eux leur volley ball du châble
non ce soir
[Applaudissements]
j'attends cette visite est un petit peu
oui à toile pas sur la touche il faut
l'enlever monsieur non non non mais non
sa garde
c'est un garçon qui a l'air fort comme
ça mais au fond c'est un petit enfant
mais je ne sais pas c'est l'une de ses
premières télés et connais pas du tout
sûr tu veux visiter la régie j'adorerais
voir
mais attention ne fait pas tout
m
qu'est-ce qu'ils soient ces messieurs
ses choix alors rentrer dans le court et
bien dans les régies bien là régis et
c'est de là que le réalisateur appuyez
sur les boutons
oui voilà bons soins la plus que
spectateur
[Musique]